speaking of somebody who is well known
now jumping into the crypto industry
reese witherspoon nice reese witherspoon
has gone full degen what do i mean she
recently tweeted she said in the near
future every person will have a parallel
digital identity avatars crypto wallets
digital goods will be the norm are you
planning for this reese who is feeding
you this information where are you doing
your homework but man do i think that
you are on top of something avatars well
many people on twitter already have
avatars of course the pseudo-anonymous
economy which balaji srinivasan was very
quick to point out years ago it is
happening there's tons of people they
have crypto punks they have bored apes
or they have things like rhys has right
here on her twitter account tons and
tons of people using avatars rather than
their real photos obviously crypto
wallets becoming absolutely pervasive
hundreds of millions of people with them
and you see it not only being used to
actually hold economic value but also
all the things around airdrops you're
being able to sign in using your crypto
wallet this stuff is coming and you can
already see it working it's a better
system it's more efficient it's faster
and ultimately what i think is that your
browser something like the brave browser
literally it's just going to have the
wallet baked right in and so regardless
of whether you're using an application
whether you're using something that's
peer-to-peer open source or you're
simply using the browser itself crypto
wallets will only become more pervasive
over time and then of course digital
goods well we already buy tons of
digital goods when you buy netflix
you're buying a digital good when you
buy a song on itunes or let's say an
audio book those are digital goods we've
had it for a long time the more the
world changes the more it stays the same
but the digital goods are changing
there's a different type of digital good
now of course there's things that are
tokenized everything from nfts to
bitcoin everything in between digital
goods are here because we don't actually
live in a geographically constrained
analog economy anymore nobody goes to
the store at the same rate that they
used to instead what we are seeing is
that now we live in a digitally native
economy if you're under the age of maybe
40 or 45 you live on the internet you
buy things on the internet you talk on
the internet everything you do revolves
around the internet the internet has
made us much more connected and
ultimately boundaries like borders don't
matter nearly as much as they used to
and so that my friends is the whole key
to this and i think that reese
witherspoon is really onto something
here saying that we are going to have
parallel digital identities i'd argue
many people already care more about
their digital identity than their real
world identity why because that's where
their friends are that's where their
commerce is that's where their
reputation is and if that is the
identity in which all of that coalesce
is around then of course not only you're
going to have the digital identity but
you're going to put it on a pedestal
you're going to make sure that it
becomes pristine and that you can
continue to grow it over time
every young kid in the world whether
it's through a video game social media
or somewhere else their digital identity
is top of mind for a reason we think
they're young buck john i think we've
already seen this coming to fruition
over the last five years right avatars
uh crypto wallets digital goods owning
digital goods and services has been huge
i think this is only going to keep going
surprising that reed witherspoon got
into the mix with this tweet but uh
she's right on the ball here yeah i
think uh you're spot on when it comes to
wallets being integrated within kind of
the different websites and stuff i think
everyone eventually is going to have one
and it's going to be integrated in
basically everything you do seamlessly
like i said before a lot of this stuff
is is has a lot of friction currently
the you have to download kind of the
wallace you have to add the extensions
you have to actually go buy the the
crypto and all these different things
and there's a bunch of nuance that kind
of goes with each one of those parts but
ultimately it's not super easy for
consumer i think that has been changing
over time there's a bunch of new
onboarding ramps that weren't just hey
go buy the crypto and i think that's
been super super helpful from an
onboarding from a kind of an adoption
and an onboarding perspective but yeah i
mean this is already happening to a
large degree right covet accelerated all
this stuff by maybe five 10 15 even even
years
from like hey everyone's going to stay
at home they're all going to work from
home you're going to spend most of your
time online you're going to be on zoom
meetings
go on twitter literally half the people
that are interacting with tweets at
least in my accounts and i'm sure your
guys accounts are have avatars they're
that they're different from not only
their personal ones but even your
personal one is an avatar right it is
you're literally looking at uh at the
other person they have online identities
there are people that have more friends
online that they haven't met in real
life so all this is already happening to
some degree it's just been accelerated
over the last couple of years where does
it go in 5 10 15 years i think more is
the question because
it's become apparent right you you
everyone spends most of people at least
here within the developed united states
spend the majority of their time online
a lot of people haven't gone back to
work or at least doing it on kind of a
partial basis spending a lot of their
time online and then it just comes down
to like where does all of this live
right is it a one metaverse is it
multiple metaphors is it just online how
we see it today where does this all
transact but ultimately yeah i don't
think it's very uh uh out of line of of
reese to say everyone's going to have an
avatar everyone's going to have a
digital wallet everyone's going to
transact online everyone's going to hang
out online everyone's going to do these
things because to a degree all this is
already happening it's just being
accelerated and seeing how more people
are picking this up on a daily basis